[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri ser ihn allen guten Abend wir
haben heute einiges im Angebot
sportliches gehört dazu mit christinto
natürlich viel Fußball guten Abend dann
sind hier unsere Thema an diesem
Donnerstag
Orban knickt ein der EU-Gipfel
beschließt Milliardenhilfen für die
Ukraine
einstimmig abheben ist Glückssache weil
das Sicherheitspersonal streigt fallen
bundesweit mehr als
1100 Flüge
aus und zu wenig Regen seit 40 Monaten
die Region um Barcelona muss schon im
Winter den dürrenotstand
verhängen ja damit war nicht unbedingt
zu rechnen die EU hat sich überraschend
schnell auf 50 Milliarden Euro
Finanzhilfe für die Ukraine geeinigt
überraschend weil Ungarn das Beziehungen
zu Russland pflegt und die Hilfen bis
zuletzt blockierte doch noch überzeugt
werden konnte
50 Milliarden für die kommenden 4er
Jahre das macht zinhalb Milliarden pro
Jahr das Geld aus dem EU-Haushalt fließt
nicht direkt in den Verteidigungskrieg
gegen Russland es soll Kiev etwa helfen
Löhne und Renten auszuzahlen oder den
Betrieb in Krankenhäusern und Schulen
abzusichern EBO die Energie und
Wasserversorgung wie es zu der
überraschend reibungslosen Freigabe des
Geldes kam da Florian neuhn aus
Brüssel alskorbann am Vormittag den
gipfelsaal betritt ist die Stimmung
bereits gelöst kurz vorher hatte der
ungarische Ministerpräsident klein B und
sein Veto gegen die ukrainehilfe
aufgegeben zu heftig war wohl die Kritik
aus allen Richtungen wie am Morgen vom
polnischen
premier die Position von Orban ist eine
Bedrohung unserer Sicherheit das ist
offensichtlich und
inakzeptabel EUR für vi Jahre diese
Summe wollte die EU der Ukraine schon im
Dezember Zusagen damals scheiterte man
am Veto von Orban heute deshalb ein
Sondergipfel der Durchbruch gelingt wohl
im kleinen Kreis vor Beginn zuletzt
hatte Orban eine jährliche Abstimmung
verlangt quasi ein jährliches Vetorecht
die Runde sagt ihm deutlich weniger zu
man werde jährlich über die Umsetzung
des Hilfsprogramms reden jede Änderung
aber müsste einstimmig beschlossen
werden kurzfit des
Kanzlers gute Botschaft für die
Europäische Union gute Botschaft für die
Ukraine und für mich deshalb heute die
Zusammenfassung das war ein sehr
erfolgreicher Gipfel wie immer kurz per
Video zugeschaltet der ukrainische
Präsident volodimir selenski bedankt
sich für das einstimmige Votum der
EU-Spitzen das ist ein klares Signal
dass die Ukraine bestehen wird und dass
Europa bestehen
wird die EU musste heute Nachsitzen aber
sie beendet diesen Gipfel ausnahmsweise
deutlich früher und auch erfolgreicher
als
erwartet wir gehen nach Brüssel zu Ulf
Röller Ulf Ungarns Regierungschef Orban
hat sein Veto gegen Finanzhilfen
überraschend schnell aufgegeben woran
lag's ich glaube einfach der Druck wurde
für victtor Orban einfach zu groß die 26
anderen Regierungschefs haben sehr sehr
deutlich gemacht wie isoliert er gewesen
ist und sie haben auch sehr deutlich
gemacht welche Konsequenzen es für Orban
hat wenn er weiter blockiert z.B ist
darüber diskutiert worden ganz offen in
Brüssel ob man Orban den geldharn
zudreht man muss wissen die ungarische
Wirtschaft braucht das EU-Geld die hängt
quasi am Tropf des eu-geldes und das
wäre ein schwerer Schlag für die
ungarische Wirtschaft gewesen das wollte
er wohl vermeiden und dann ist sogar
darüber nachgedacht worden in Brüssel
ihm das Stimmrecht vielleicht zu
entziehen das ist ein komplizierter
Prozess aber allein die Drohung hat wohl
gereicht um ihn dann zum Einlenken zu
bringen was heißt das was heißt das für
Europa es ist heute ein Sieg ein Triumph
für das demokratische Europa und es ist
eine Niederlage für den
autoritärdenkenden Viktor Orban vielen
Dank olulf Röller nach Brüssel also alle
Augen waren auf die Stadt gerichtet
heute wegen eben des EU-Gipfels und das
nutzten auch die Bauern die gerade in
vielen europäischen Ländern protestieren
mit etwa 1300 Traktoren fuhren sie vor
die EU-Zentrale einige warfen
Feuerwerkskörper Eier und Bierflaschen
die Polizei hielt mit Wasserwerfern
dagegen die Landwirte beklagen sinkende
Einnahmen zu viele Umweltvorschriften
und bürokratische Vorgaben außerdem die
billigere Konkurrenz aus nicht
EU-Ländern wir bleiben in Brüssel wo mit
dem geplanten EU lieferkettengesetz ein
Prestigeprojekt auf der Kippe steht weil
Deutschland genauer die FDP die Pläne
nun doch nicht mittragen will zwar
unterstütze man das Ziel Menschenrechte
und Umwelt besser zu schützen aber nicht
zulasten deutscher Wirtschaftsinteressen
so die Liberalen der Koalitionspartner
SPD ist verärgert aber in Teilen der
Wirtschaft wird aufgeatmet mehr von Gunn
Krüger in Hamm in Westfalen haben sie
was Kantinen brauchen 20.000 Produkte
aus aller Welt alle müssen laut Entwurf
zum Lieferketten
sorgfalltspflichtengesetz künftig Umwelt
und Arbeitsstandards erfüllen und die
Chefin muss das nachweisen wir wollen
natürlich Umweltschutz und
Menschenrechte einhalten das ist wichtig
aber wir brauchen hier Lösungen die
machbar die praktikabel und die auch
bezahlbar sind doch der Entwurf gilt je
nach Risiko schon für Betriebe ab 250
Mitarbeitern die sorgfalltspflicht
reicht von Rohstoffen über alle
Zwischenhändler bis zur Produktion damit
wäre das EU-Gesetz strenger als das
bestehende deutsche lieferkettengesetz
darum sagt die FDP jetzt doch nein es
wäre besser diesen Entwurf beiseite zu
legen und die Alternative ist dann nicht
nichts tun sondern ich werbe für einen
frischen stat nach der Wahl des
Europäischen Parlaments der Kompromiss
vom Dezember sei mit heißer Nadel
gestrickt aber die Bundesregierung
drückte damals Vorbehalte der FDP durch
wenn sie sich nun im streitenthält für
Spiele sie Vertrauen so die Grünen man
zu kurz vchuss die reileine zieht ist
europapolitisch unverantwortlich und
darum gibt der federführende Minister
hallo noch nicht auf ich werbe
eindrücklich für eine Zustimmung zu
diesem zu dieser Richtlinie und ich habe
dazu einen Vorschlag unterbreitet den
wir jetzt in der Regierung diskutieren
um Brücken zu bauen Unternehmen wie das
in HAM müssten Bedenken gleiche Regeln
für alle in der EU sorgen für fairen
Wettbewerb schauen wir auf den Krieg in
der Ukraine da meldet die Armee einen
Schlag gegen die russische Marine
demnach soll ein russisches Kriegsschiff
im Schwarzen Meer versenkt worden sein
das ukrainische Militär veröffentlichte
ein Video auf dem zu sehen ist wie
Drohnen ein Schiff angreifen es habe
Schlagseite bekommen und sei gesunken
Moskau hat sich bisher nicht dazu
geäußert und Einschätzungen dazu und zur
Lage in der Ukraine von einem
Militärexperten um 19:30 Uhr bei z heute
live wie immer in der ZDF heute App und
auf unseren Social Media
Kanälen fast
1,7 Millionen Menschen in Deutschland
fordern dass dem rechtsextremen
parteichf der Thüringer AFD Björn höcke
Grundrechte entzogen werden eine
entsprechende Petition übergab der
Initiator an
bundestagspolitiker dadurch soll höcke
das Recht verlieren sich wählen zu
lassen für einen Entzug der Grundrechte
gelten allerdings juristisch hohe Hürden
gezeigt Reisende brauchen in diesen
Tagen ziemlich starke Nerven letzte
Woche der Bahnstreik morgen will die
Gewerkschaft wer die bundesweit den
öffentlichen Personenverkehr bestreiken
heute waren
deutsche Flughäfen weitgehend lahm
gelegt weil das Sicherheitspersonal im
Ausstand ist laut Flughafenverband
wirbelte das die Pläne von ungefähr
200.000 Passagieren durcheinander mehr
als 1100 Flüge fielen komplett aus oder
starteten verspätet zum Tarifstreit
jetzt Markus
wolsiffer die Botschaft eindeutig ohne
sie geht kaum was an den Flughäfen das
Sicherheitspersonal im Streik mehr als
ein Drittel der geplanten Flüge fiel
allein hier in Düsseldorf aus der Streik
tue weh er sei jedoch dringend nötig
argumentiert werdi jer sieht ja selbst
in seinem Geldbeutel wie die Preise
gestiegen sind und da muss auch bei den
Kolleginnen sich was tun auch damit der
Beruf weiter attraktiv bleibt in den
bisher drei Tarifrunden keine Einigung
Forderungen und Angebote liegen weiter
auseinander und sind schwer vergleichbar
werdi fordert 2,80 € mehr in der Stunde
die Arbeitgeber bieten 4% mehr in diesem
und 3% mehr im nächsten Jahr nach
Angaben von Verdi lehnen die Arbeitgeber
die Forderung nach höheren
funktionszulagen genauso ab wie
mehrarbeitszuschläge ab der ersten
Überstunde zudem will werdi nur 12
Monate Laufzeit die Arbeitgeber bieten
24 der Streik sei überzogen finden die
Arbeitgeber leitragende seinen allein
heute 200.000 Reisende wir haben in den
letzten 3 Jahren die endgelder um 19%
erhöht im Durchschnitt ja wir liegen im
Moment bei 20, 60 Stundenlohn brutto das
ist wie wir finden sehr angemessen
kolleginn Kollegen erreichen 3600 brutto
im Monat im Durchschnitt diederungen des
Sicherheitspersonals würden die
Arbeitgeber nach eigener Aussage eine
viertel Milliarde Euro mehr kosten nur
für 2024 der Verband fordert eine
Schlichtung werdi lnt das bisher ab
Begründung man wolle keinen Einfluss
Dritter
die Deutsche Bank will ihren Sparkurs
fortsetzen und weltweit 3500 Stellen
abbauen Kostendisziplin habe weiter
allerhöchste Priorität sagte Konzernchef
sewing bei der
jahresbilanzpressekonferenz in Frankfurt
die Bank stellt sich damit auf einen
Rückgang der Zinsen und auf schwächere
gewinne ein zuletzt hatte das
Unternehmen 90.000
Mitarbeiter ob Fiebersaft
Blutdruckmittel oder antibiotik immer
wieder sind Medikamente knapp oder gar
nicht zu bekommen aktuell mangelt an
einem HIV Medikament das 10ta000
Menschen in Deutschland zum Schutz vor
einer Infektion nehmen Hersteller hatten
die Produktion eingestellt oder
Lieferengpässe gemeldet die ahilfe war
jetzt vor fatalen Folgen Dominik tepka
berichtet für Jörn falldorf kommt die
Angst vor HIV zurück eigentlich nimmt er
Tabletten die ihn vor einer Ansteckung
beim Sex mit anderen Männern schützen
doch seine Apotheke hat dieses
Medikament die sogenannte prep seit
Wochen nicht mehr
vorrätig ich bin in der Generation groß
geworden wo eine HIV Infektion wirklich
ganz
dramatische Folgen hatte und die alte
Angst vor HIV kommt kommt wieder vor
Ansteckung und das ist ein ziemlich
beschissenes Gefühl um das mal sehr
deutlich zu sagen in Deutschland nehmen
rund 40.000 vor allem schwule Männer die
prep auch einige HIV positive Menschen
sind auf den Wirkstoff angewiesen
Gesundheitsminister Lauterbach hat heute
offiziell den Versorgungsengpass für
dieses Medikament ausgerufen das kann
jetzt leichter aus dem Ausland
importiert
werden es ist gut dass das jetzt sehr
klar offiziell so gesagt und deklariert
wird das macht erst einmal öffentlich
deutlich dass es ein großes Problem gibt
Grund für den Mangel zwei Hersteller
haben die Produktion eingestellt ein
generelles Problem in Deutschland auch
andere teils sehr spezielle Medikamente
sind knapp fast 500 wir müssen den
Produktionsstandort für Medikamente in
Europa insgesamt stärken das ist eine
Aufgabe für die gesamte Europäische
Union aber auch für Deutschland das
betrifft einerseits
natürlich HIV Medikation aber es
betrifft auch ganz viele andere
Medikamente bei der prep haben
Hersteller heute zusätzliche Lieferungen
angekündigt experten rechnen aber damit
dass das Medikament trotzdem bis Mitte
März knapp bleiben
wird jetzt der Blick nach Spanien wo sie
seit Jahren unter extremer Dürre leiden
und das nicht nur im son Sommer sondern
auch jetzt im Winter in Katalonien im
Osten von Spanien sind die
Trinkwasserreservoirs so ausgetrocknet
dass die Regionalregierung jetzt den
Wassernotstand ausruft betroffen sind
rund 200 Städte und Gemeinden darunter
die Region Barcelona mit fast 6
Millionen Einwohnern Anne Arend
berichtet diese Kirche stand einst
Unterwasser geflutet von einem Staus der
die Millionenmetropole Barcelona
versorgen sollte doch der Speicher ist
nahe zuu leer liegt nur noch bei
4% Katalonien leidet unter der
schlimmsten Dürre seit 100 Jahren
seitdem wir die Niederschläge
aufzeichnen waren wir noch nie mit einer
so langen und extremen Trockenheit
konfrontiert wie in den letzten 40
Monaten Dürre Notstand das heißt pro
Einwohner dürfen maximal 200 l am Tag
verbraucht werden doch die verteilen
sich auch auf städtische Einrichtungen
und Gewerbe für Privathaushalte bleibt
somit
weniger alle die Jungen die alten wir
müssen unser Bewusstsein ändern vor
allem unsere täglichen
Gewohnheiten ich glaube dass noch immer
nicht allen klar ist was der Klimawandel
bedeutet und dass es ohne Wasser kein
Leben geben
kann betroffen ist auch der Tourismus
duschen müssen abgestellt werden Pools
dürfen nicht nicht neu befüllt werden im
Winter mag das verkraftbar sein doch
viele denken mit Sorge an die
Ostersaison wir werden eine
Aufklärungskampagne starten und die
Urlauber zu einem verantwortungsvollen
Wasserkonsum
bewegen mit dem entsalzen von Meerwasser
versuchen sie im Großraum Barcelona die
Krise abzufedern alle rechnen damit dass
die Dürre lange anhalten
wird Dürren und andere Probleme werden
höchstwahrscheinlich schon sehr bald
auch mit Hilfe künstlicher Intelligenz
gemanaged bei uns im ZDF da kommt die KI
in einigen Bereichen schon zum Einsatz
wird aber gleichzeitig wegen möglicher
Gefahren auch kritisch hinterfragt in
der Filmwelt ist das Thema omnipräsent
ob als jobkillerszenario oder als
fiktiver drehbuchstoff beides ist heute
Abend auch Thema beim ZF medientreff in
Berlin Nils
Schneider eine utopische Stadt in
Schweden nach einem furchtbaren amlauf
gehen die bewoh neue Wege sie gründen
die Siedlung Concordia eine künstliche
Intelligenz überwacht dort alle
Lebensbereiche so sollen die Menschen in
Sicherheit leben ihre Daten dabei
geschützt sein doch als ein Mord
passiert bekommt die vermeintlich heile
Welt Risse im Herbst wird die Miniserie
ausgestrahlt bisher existiert nur die
Rohfassung auf Englisch Christiane Paul
spielt die Hauptrolle der
internationalen ZF Produktion als
Schöpferin der
[Musik]
KI
die Figur hat eine große Ambivalenz was
ich auch spannend fand eine Frau in
Macht zu sehen die aber doch auch wie so
eine ja nicht eine Mutter der Nation ist
falsch aber doch sehr sich um ihre
Bewohner auch kümmert und sorgt
künstliche Intelligenz in immer mehr
Lebens und Arbeitsbereichen wird diese
Technik eingesetzt so auch im ZDF
Untertitel z.B werden so erstellt
Nachrichten könnten ganz automatisch in
eine andere Sprache übersetzt werden
in Berlin informiert das ZDF über die
Pläne mit KI auf einer Diskussionsrunde
mit Vertretern aus Politik und
Medienwirtschaft wie in allen Branchen
ist KI für uns in den Medien bedeutsam
aber für ein öffentlichrechtlichen
Sender erst recht schauen Sie die Wahlen
in diesem Jahr die Fake News die jetzt
verbreitet werden auf diversen
Plattformen ganz oft mit KI schon
generiert die müssen wir aufdecken wir
müssen aber auch uns mit KI so gut
auskennen dass wir eben den Publikum
vermitteln können wo das passiert und
wie es passiert das ZDF hat sich eigene
Regeln für KI gegeben daneben auch
offenelegt wie seine Computerprogramme
mit künstlicher Intelligenz
funktionieren und programmiert
sind bei uns geht's jetzt sportlich
weiter Christin im DFB Pokal stehen
jetzt die ersten beiden Halbfinalisten
fest neben Fortuna Düsseldorf auch
Kaisers Lautern zwei Zweitligisten der
Traum vom dritten Pokalsieg nach 1990
und96 lebt weiter beim ersten FC Kaisers
lauter im ausverkauften Berliner Olympia
stad dominieren die pfelzer die Partie
gegen die Hausherren mit 3:1 bei Herter
BSC Frust und
Enttäuschung Herter Trainer Pal Dardai
findet einen ungewöhnlichen Grund für
die Niederlage jetzt die halbe
Mannschaft mit Spritze gespielt mit
Medikamente und alles weil wir begripper
gerade da drinne wir sind dieses Jahr
2024 ein bisschen verhext nicht verhext
aber doch verschlafen wirkt die Härte
Abwehr bei allen drei Lauterer Treffern
der Zweitliga Abstiegskandidat aus der
Pfalz mit großer Entschlossenheit trotz
nur 30% Ballbesitz und mit sehenswerten
Zugaben Tei Berlin vergibt die Chance
auf ein Heimspiel im Finale die lautere
und ihre Fans nur noch ein Spiel
entfernt von der Rückkehr nach Berlin
Überraschung in der Formel 1
Rekordweltmeister lewiis Hamilton
wechselt nach übereinstimmenden
Medienberichten
2025 von Mercedes zu Ferrari
Fußballnationalspieler Mahmut DAH Hut
kehrt in die Bundesliga zurück der
Mittelfeldspieler kommt vom Premier
League Club Brighton en Hof elbirn zum
VfB Stuttgart die Schwaben leihen ihn
zunächst bis Saisonende aus die Frauen
von Eintracht Frankfurt beenden die
aktuelle Champions League Saison mit
einem Sieg im sportlich bedeutungslosen
letzten Gruppenspiel setzen sie sich
gegen die schwedinen vom FC Rosengart
mit 5:0 durch Frankfurts Vorrunden aus
in der Königsklasse stand bereits vor
der Partie
fest Jürgen kloppp strahlt bei seiner
Abschiedstour 4:1 gewinnt der FC
Liverpool gegen den FC Chelsea und
festigt die Tabellenführung in der
englischen Liga Jürgen Klopp erlebt
einen rundum gelungenen
Arbeitstag was für eine großartige Nacht
diese Atmosphäre was für ein Spiel ein
Traum es beginnt mit jogo JS 1:0 Führung
in Enfield noch in Halbzeit 1 legt
Youngster Connor Bradley nach 20 Jahre
alt und einer der besten auf dem Platz
weitere Glücksmomente erlebt Jürgen
Klopp in Halbzeit 2 schoboschle erhöht
zum 3:0 nachdem chelseaen kunku der
Anschlusstreffer gelingt setzt Luis Diaz
den Schlusspunkt zur 4 zu ein
Gala ja wie gesagt er strahlt zurecht
wie ich finde vielen Dank Christin wir
kann können ihn zum Wetter so viel sagen
weiterhin relativ mildes Winterwetter
Einzelheiten gleich von östen terli ich
empfehle Ihnen gerne noch das heute
journal um 21:45 Uhr mit Marietta Slomka
vom gesamten heute Team der 19 Uhr
schönen Dank fürs zus und einen
entspannten
[Musik]
Abend schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter die abziehende
Kaltfront bringt in der Nacht noch etwas
Regen und Schnee hier in den Alpen aber
verschiebt sich allmählich ostwärts aber
die nächste Front kommt das ist diese
Warmfront die überquert uns morgen im
Tagesverlauf und bringt neuen Regen
bereits in der Nacht im Nordwesten hier
sehen wir die Wolken die dazu gehören
ganz im Süden da gibt's noch Regen und
Schnee das wird allmählich weniger
gehört noch zur Kaltfront die
Temperaturen dazu ja eisig hier zwischen
Saarland und Bayerischer Wald -2° hier
der tiefstswert 5° Plus im Nordwesten
deutlich milder morgen im Tagesverlauf
dann viele Wolken die allmählich
ostwärts ziehen vor allem hier im Norden
viel Regen teilweise in den höheren
Lagen dann Schneefall und von Westen her
Lock hat es dann zu Nachmittag auf und
die Sonne zeigt sich bei höchsten
Temperaturen von 3° hier in den
östlichen Mittelgebirgen 10° im Westen
und 11° am oberrehein und die nächsten
Tage nun es ist immer wieder etwas Regen
dabei vor allem hier über der Mitte der
langsam ostwts zieht im Süden teilweise
Sonnenschein am Samstag bei 5 bis 11°
danach wird's deutlich milder Sonntag
bis 14 und Montag sogar 16° und damit
einen schönen Abend